on écoute les précisions de notre envoyé
spécial du livre craag hier soir on a
vraiment entendue depuis le centre de
kiev des combats intenses venant de la
direction du nord-ouest donc dire pin
rosto mail bush à qui on sait c'est aux
alentours de minuit plus ou moins mais
il est difficile de dire si ce sont des
russes qui en réalité continue
d'attaquer ou si ce sont juste les
contre attaques ukrainienne qui continue
le président volodymyr zelensky dans son
allocution aux ukrainiens tard hier soir
a dit que les ukrainiens savent très
bien que si les russes quittent ces
territoires en ce moment ce n'est pas à
cause d'une décision stratégique ou
parce que c'est mission accomplie mais
c'est tout le contraire c'est parce
qu'ils sont et ce sont les mots de
vladimir zelensky chassés de ces
territoires mais il a dit tout de suite
après que les ukrainiens ne doivent
absolument pas baisser leur garde qu'il
ne croit pas du tout aux maux des russes
est d'ailleurs les attaques qui ont
continué sur terre ni give un peu plus
au nord prouve que les l'intention des
russes de cesser l'activité militaires
dans ces régions qui avaient cerné gif
n'était pas vraiment
conforme à la réalité de leurs
intentions et voilà donc volodymyr
zelensky qui estime tout comme les
militaires eux craignant que les russes
vont continuer de préparer des attaques
que ce soit sur la région de kiev ou sur
les régions d'une basse et je pense
qu'en réalité les sentiments en ukraine
c'est un peu la peur de la revanche que
la revanche sera peut-être plus dures de
la part de vladimir poutine ainsi il a
été humilié comme c'est le cas du moins
en partie par la force de la défense
ukrainienne et la faiblesse et le moral
bas de l'armée russe qui s'est révélé au
cours des dernières semaines c'est
peut-être bon pour le moral des
ukrainiens pour le moment d'avoir ces
victoires mais à la longue est-ce que
cela ne veut pas dire que la réponse et
la brutalité des russes ne sera pas
encore plus forte et le bombardement de
churn équipe qui continue le montre
peut-être parce qu'on a l'impression que
les civils sont de plus en plus ciblés
dans cette ville du nord de l'ukraine